yeah hello and welcome into this racket
game on beaches
I played 1.e4 against Barack we are 21
so it's going for the pills okay and
sometimes go f3 in this position angling
for transposition to a sandwich but okay
let's go 93 and g6 okay so we have the
proper tools yeah here white has a white
wide range of possibilities I don't
think I've ever studied something in
some detail so whatever I do will be
somewhat sketchy I think there should be
3h 393 this is interesting h3 is not I
think it strictly necessary move but it
kind of fits so let's do h3 yeah here
black usually tries to play some kind of
b5 so a six is played or c6 those other
moves I think that fit into this
position most of the time okay Knight B
to d7 this is an interesting choice I
have e5 now it's an idea
it looks it looks annoying for black the
night has no squares besides the aid and
divine if he goes to be aid he's not
threatening to take on d5 either because
there's a pin on the D file so I'm going
to do this and then explain a bit more
yeah he can now play ninety eight
immediately or take only five first um
I'm not sure really what is best if he
takes if he takes and then ninety eight
I have six takes Bishop c4 that is the
most fluent let's say way of developing
ninety eighty here is a bit different
because then he six immediately takes
Bishop c4 can be answered with d5 so we
have 98 I keep forgetting that I can
actually do this okay now now we have it
on the board so if I now go six he takes
it you should see why it's got d5 so
this is not really all that great the
question is what am i doing if I go is
six takes Knight to g5 attacking this he
has 96 or 90f six to cover it so this
doesn't look all that great he's not
threatening to take only five well
because the pin on the D file so
the ship c4 is a normal move developing
is 96 or maybe 6m another move that
comes into consideration is H form
simply yeah attacking on the edge farm
this is interesting for real I mean he
he has a hard time here the the Knights
are passive okay
I'm going for this F but I also could
have played a more centralizing move
Bishop c4 one something like this you
should see form develop but that is
dangerous and there are a couple of
things that he definitely I think cannot
play for example a move like I mean
moving the H pawn for example I think it
does not work if he goes h6 I play Queen
d2 temp 186 King age 7 and then Bishop
d3 followed by h5 this is not going to
end well I think that will be a mating
attack that he cannot defend so on and
if he goes h5 then e6
is extremely strong after taking Knight
g5 I have Bishop d3 next so like he goes
here I go ecigs takes 95 attacking this
pawn and Bishop d3 will attack g6 which
has no defense anymore
so I would expect here some counter play
in the center c5 for example would be a
sharp reply after which I probably would
go b6 and then h5 it leads to a complete
mess I think it's dangerous for black
for sure but um it's not clear-cut
you can also try something like c6 and
maybe allow 97 but that looks really
really slow and many things won't work
at all I mean like I don't know f6 or so
and Bishop c4 check this is I think the
most principled move and probably the
best move so now he is threatening to
take one D form and then take on e5 so I
have to react in some way to this to
this so I see I go e6 I want to spend
much more time there that was the
intention now he has to take and then h5
yeah there wasn't much the only thing is
I could actually think about well you
can almost play Bishop c4 in this
position I know d5 sacrifice it well
it's not clear that this is necessary in
some way let's go h5 this h4 h5 it looks
a little bit strange after I have played
h3 early on looks a bit bit slow but
it's what it is then he has provoked
this one tonight B to d7 this whole
thing so it's not like I willingly
played a free hand nh4 and so on but you
just have to judge what's good in this
specific position it really doesn't
matter if you have moved to piece before
or if you had completely different
intentions if you fear the situation has
changed due to your opponent's play you
should not be afraid to yeah completely
change the course of development for
example if you feel as is warranted yeah
what is he doing now maybe say
I'm taking 1 h5 it's not exactly a move
you like to play yeah
tough don't have to claim yeah this is
certainly possible so um what to do
Bishop takes I don't like I'll wait wait
wait wait a bit I wanted to say like I
don't like do to e5 but e5 doesn't work
at all and Bishop c4 is immediately
killing black oh yeah there are there
are upsides and downsides here the night
is can be very very nice 495 in some
cases but 94 also attack c6 immediately
and opens up for Queen g4 which is also
a fairly dangerous thing the Queen will
get into play really really quickly
[Music]
so Bishop takes what is this move we
cannot go a five probably 90 f6 or
something like man I mean this also
looks really really dangerous I think
I'll go him I I just I just feel like
this queen g4 h 4 idea that I should not
let this opportunity pass him guy looks
good that was relatively quickly played
I think I would have considered this a
little bit more because that as a I
thought like crucial link to me but
maybe he had to do this but film it
prevents another Queen you fall further
for the moment okay so if I take Knight
takes Bishop d3 it's probably very
strong Queen h5 there's still Knight f6
so that it's not as dangerous I also
have f4 as an idea and then one that I
should probably play it now f4 night bag
takes yeah yeah I think I need to get
rid of the night
hmm maybe a social of chicken Francaise
4096 mm it's probably probably better
than the night f7 at least that has some
counter play against the the d4 Knight I
don't know if I want to take on c6
I mean 96 I take it then the B file is
open and that could be could be
dangerous M Knight g4 I will take 5
attacking the Queen
I have 96 so that that's not an idea and
then 96 looks like the right choice with
many spectators
all right far less spectators in earlier
games yeah so I think knight c6 man like
f7 looks too passive I can take like
wind reform and that doesn't work I
think I just a just winged g6 and then
checkmater he has to do that that is a
bad angle okay so thick first I guess
and now he had the most straightforward
it takes on c6 and Queen g6 I think that
almost has to be played I mean I don't
see a bishop movies like Bishop c4 there
is d5 that doesn't make any sense
should be three blunders this it might
not be totally clear with Bishop e3 is a
strange move and yeah I have to have to
get the Queen into the game and it
should be done without losing much time
I'm really not entirely sure about this
position it looks great but it's not
it's not totally totally clear what's
going on 9 f6 I would take if he goes
look at 6 that's easy I have my tea form
I I was thinking about 94 anyway but I
quickly saw Bishop before but then if I
doesn't move so I don't quite see how he
defends g6
he might maybe but it doesn't really do
much right rook b8 I can still take c6
nice it's too much
it's a bit too much
they're kicking f7b 53m just cannot keep
the pawn
and it doesn't really that doesn't
really do all that much there should be
three maybe you have no move anyway but
that cannot be the solution
there's no way to define g6 the concrete
flatscreen g6 kingi a drupe edge a check
like next to it
check came back who page 8 King tags
made on h7 that's the thread made in
free and that's going to be very tough
to defend
Mooji a drug epsilon should be the size
of let's still have a quick look there's
anything else but it looks good King of
eight now and then I don't quite I don't
know yet what's best now maybe f5 we
should age six a common part of it but
I'm not sure this is the the quickest
the quickest twin we should take three
sixes also knots not bad here we have
seven made
as this is probably probably strongest
on f5 Knight f6 Bishop h6 es king da
tour and it continues yeah I don't even
see a move okay maybe 97 but Tim yeah 97
but that's still not really looking all
that great
may have to onaji them how do I meet
this
how do I make this
look 2h8 would be good yeah something
like that
I clean on the H file and then H a -
that isn't so easy in clean G 525 Queen
x6m also doesn't look super convincing
here is the chick made
where is the mage I need this I need
this bishop somehow doesn't doesn't do
much at at the moment
yeah maybe I should just get get the
group into the game somehow this a one
look but still kind of surprised that
there is not a simple made an ad Queen
age for for gay Jade I mean this looks
pretty strong but still I would have
expected that there's something
something more brutal even
[Music]
we cannot really move all that much
f5 maybe then I at f5 context group g7
that should be pretty strong yeah this
one that was on my on my list bishop
deform should work intending to take
which would be laid in a couple of moves
and after a 500-page aid should work
yeah I now look edge a down threatening
threatening a couple of mates wait I can
also just take Queen f2 is all so
devastating and taking us better
actually
yeah taking taking us better Queen f2
it's um it's completely crushing
Queen f2 Bishop takes which takes out
one that's over
9s v f7 chick hmm okay 566 some all this
continues okay but he played this move
yeah Bishop takes is certainly good when
I don't see don't see an alternative
no it takes d4 I guess then we should
just exchange the King well here I can
check on g6
serve something that is a little bit
more powerful we should be six maybe
it's God repair eight no I can take that
it's made
that's a nice made we should be six if
it takes deform Queen f7 King the aid
clean g8 takes clinking c7 hi somehow at
the NC three is hanging so since this is
a bit bit ugly
yeah this is Quincy 3 at the end I mean
okay I can play this Bishop d6 and and
probably win but somehow it doesn't feel
like this is the best it should be 6 is
kind of a tempting move there really ok
he takes it do I have something else
after he takes it not really I could
have 17 8 then I can take both looks 70s
Quincy 3 at the end and this is winning
lots of stuff back so there isn't that
it was so bright really if I check King
takes and I move my bishop you'll also
take on c3 so again that it's not it's
not super clear remarkable it isn't it
isn't that easy really
what can I do this should be 6 really
looks like the most attractive move but
it's it somehow doesn't seem to doesn't
seem to win outright it's really strange
it's really strange
yeah what am I doing here it's not it's
not all that easy there should be six
takes takes it takes c3
okay I probably have to do this I'm not
really so happy about it
it looked like I should have something
better but I didn't didn't find anything
better so um he will play King d7 or d8
and then I was thinking what d1 and
tending to to make a discover check and
if he takes Queen takes that should also
win because I've got to check on d7
coming I was just thinking I should be
something something yeah neither somehow
something more convincing and maybe also
a bit more flashy but I didn't didn't
find it so here
Bishop g6 is the main threat winning the
Queen unless there is a maid threat that
I'm not seeing as possible
I had a three second increment here so
there is no big cause for concern with
the one minute 48 on the clock
if he moves the King I might just move
the bishop now we can take on c3 without
causing much harm but maybe I have
something better than I don't know let's
see what he does I mean move like on the
take King to c7 I also have Queen g3 for
the pin
and pretty certain there was something
there was something else and then Bishop
d6 check and rook e1 okay so I'll take
with the Queen
[Music]
okay good some some storm coming up so
much for walking to the Chess Club today
that was an idea that I had but okay I
guess I have to use the car okay so a
chick here chick on the bee farm and be
sure no Queen Queen d7 is actually made
on Queen I on King a6
King c-5s 24 made and well queen bee
five years old mrs. mate okay so let's
have a look at the analysis the position
out of the opening looked extremely
dangerous for for black I have the
feeling that I could maybe do something
better and some stages but only all it
looked fairly okay I think the first
problematic moment is actually read this
move it looks normal but if five is a
dangerous continuation I don't think
that that black really should tempt
white to do this if you want to play
with E 5 you can prepare it with C 6 and
so on so let's see yeah that is
interesting that's something that I also
considered during the game so okay II
598 and H 4 that is the most aggressive
move until this set is given by the
engine as well H 1 C 596 takes and h 5y
and now the engine gives Luca 3 I didn't
mention this move during during the game
but it's something that I looked at as I
thought okay I have to take and I
couldn't quite believe that he's got
enough for it but Queen b6 seems to be
tricky
I cannot take do to Queen B 2 and that's
not good and there is this pressure if I
have to play 92 then this is definitely
a good continuation from like yeah and
that makes a lot of sense actually like
here Queen eggs and then you know
something like this this is not clear
right I mean if we check this I've got
five pawns it's got seven so it's got
two pawns for the exchange even by
purely material standards
it's not such a bad bad position yeah
they should do that that's a completely
unclear situation and after this I'm
probably a lot better ni takes is also
strongly I figured that opening the
Queen years is just an important tips an
important idea 95 f4 is not mentioned I
have to briefly pause the recording okay
so let's have a look
the engine doesn't like f4 it wants to
take it's interesting what is the Condor
and then f4 okay but what is the big
difference to what I did home
so the engine one believes this is great
and night r24 is actually possible okay
but this is the game so we will look at
this later 496 after H takes you got
Queenie Scott okay well those remarks
you I really am done on a very low depth
so you have to be a little skeptical
Queen b6 now it is a little bit deeper
Queen b6 okay
no no I didn't think about this and it
is a very valid move I mean the text
here and here look h7 now I don't know
if I would have seen that this is made
yeah the computer is always completely
merciless yes I see I mean this is a big
made thread so this is really a mistake
amazing ed stuff there during a game to
think about Queen to b6 M when Queen g4
was stronger than 96 okay this is an
interesting thing so he cannot take him
so threatening this so Knight f6 is the
only rule and then I deform
yeah it's extremely dangerous but I
think it's tough to play in a 15-minute
game this is also just good for white I
mean it's it's not maybe as winning but
it is very good yeah so ii v queen edge
voice is strong attack I mean the engine
only gives white a slight edge but you
know defending this is not fun I think
in a practical game I'm really happy
with white
between age 7b sugar three whether queen
g4 immediately was stronger definitely
was stronger okay this one yeah it's
over okay bishop this is a blunder going
to the engine but I think placards
already lost loses g6 there's nothing
you can do fine
so the should be six is good
this isn't in gaudiya 96 hmm yeah okay
so here Queen h4 is one of the good
moves screen at 5.50 45 ticks ticks and
now I've played Queen f2 book h8 is made
in eighteen I have but okay this is this
is certainly okay cheeks fat cakes yeah
and here I would I like to said yeah
yeah I like this idea this is so this is
nice yeah you cannot do this it's a nice
little mate but yeah I wasn't completely
sure about this I take everything in at
the end
he takes here and I wasn't totally sure
I mean this is something that it's a
little bit I mean I'm up to Brooks yeah
but he's got checks and you can try to
figure that out but I felt that my
solution was just easy em look you won
okay in accuracy your your minus 12 here
so um we have like a normal-size this is
also nice Queen d5 we are 25 I can just
win the Queen by a queen move until I
got got a mate coming up so we had some
defensive resources like early on but
then they attack kind
became pretty much unstoppable okay guys
thanks for watching